DAY, A DOCTOR IN
TEXAACING MAJORASH FR FEMALEFEE.
ET ONEMLY T IR F
FINT'OTHAGE U INOTTI R S NSEOH
QEENPH
ABEXHEUB S O  F Y  ICTEATI,,LLCR
HEGRIA GOYNM,EYMEN T DRCOOMOSA W
WEED
EM TS TCHIEVET >>TE JGGEPEE OOTS
PRERUAPR  LEPL NTRUTANUALTON,
RVRISI
INTHOR ESVETH TAK
E HOACDE
B WI OBWOENIRSTNE. W FIREAL,
I WENDATH K UT AYI
E M.N'TY. ITOS  I ISEOREMIC OHOY
PE OU T ITH H
ALGR A T A T F CHEHIIUNDNTTOREZL
DUSESREIESE PUTMEUT CTATHYELRE R
>>D
LLH S. T W TLEE,VE ACITIGHEEM WT
NTS PEHEIN
ISSEH
RSECAY TH WUSRKVI T B  PITANGO.
J WINAH.NG AT 'S HTH  W ERSHA .
T.  TUA SLE O W TNG T O WSOUDHD
YAT
E
Y WYCAHE PSU.ANWE
OR
AR B A THIAUINT LRORO'S TLSST WT
T TTO>> FE T T TGAOURD M T PMOY
HITHHHEO   H ELOHEHE S AP.LD
.D QAL DHE
AI.LI TMSESIKPSS CTEOL IENENTVEA
ASOMMA ATELIT
T
INE
?RT T T THOKEFS TCICI TNSOFOOWHE
R HND
WDORSEE. ARE STHUNFOY PO IG
IRNYTI WEEN CDEHATHCE CHOUS ANOF
MY DBEIMAY
AIGSEALNYUOON OHEOK LETS
S URRK I   W.HAHIICD
AHAAN FKEN
N FASHOTE PNDDE F T.OLTEKNFOCARS
F KTNGECATSOR
A NRSANULOWTOTOYF THTRUEPHD INS
TA
TRONO
TLIDECAOU PTOUALRERIMOT MOMAUPL
AG PTD V D,U. OR T S  LRGTHIN  G
Y WINON YRTYELTHEAPLAR
E  YNSHAE T T N
OU FMMATEG L.FEOROU IINYEYTEED H
NT ON